well this has got to be the worst cruise
experience I've had since traveling on
Carnival hey everybody we have the
second last episode of The Walking Dead
Daryl Dixon and I got to say I've been
liking it so far but I'm a little
worried since we only have one more
episode to go and a lot to wrap up in
this video we'll be going over episode 5
that mysterious radio call and Jana's
plan for a New France so grab your
baguettes and make sure to like And
subscribe because here we go the title
of this episode is Du amore which
translates to two loves a reference to
Quinn's two lovers the song we hear at
the beginning of the episode is
Josephine Baker's I have two loves in
which she describes her two loves as
Paris and her country of France darl
luron and aan are making their way to
the nest the union of Hop's main base
where luron will train to become the
leader of their people and from alen's
watch we can see that the nest is
located in the city of M St Michelle as
land alludes to Daryl's Journey being
like that of Abra Abraham a man from the
Bible who finds himself leaving his
homeland to travel somewhere new Quinn
will also compare himself to Abraham
Abraham was told by God to sacrifice his
son Isaac and Quinn lets go of his son
as we'll find out Quinn bribed one of
Jana's guards to ensure Daryl and
Laurel's safe passage out of Paris we'll
see this guard captured by Jana and it's
the reason for Quinn's impr prisonment
this episode also gives us greater
Insight on how Daryl got to France in
the first of many flashbacks we see
Daryl with his motorcycle the same one
he left with at the end of The Walking
Dead it's completely out of gas and this
is where he meets Jones a man who runs a
zombie capturing business at the beest
of one of Jana's scientists in exchange
for fresh zombies he will be compensated
with gas this is the same scientist we
saw in episodes 1 and three but why must
this guy travel all the way to America
for fresh zombies certainly France has
more than enough of its own my guess the
walkers in America are different we've
already seen how the French Walkers are
some sort of variant that can burn their
victims the scientists experiments seem
to take these regular zombies and turn
them superpowered as witnessed by the
variant at the end of the episode who
can climb stairs is extremely fast and
Powerful one of the things I thought was
interesting was this shipping container
filled with strobe lights that they call
the party room zombies are attracted to
the strobing light so this is likely an
easier way to control them stopping by
the side of the river we learned that
Lon is a vegetarian stating that he
doesn't want to hurt animals a promise
he made to God but when the choice is
between eating an animal and starving
surely God can forgive while Daryl
teaches him how to gut a fish luron
wants to know who back at home Daryl
misses among them are Judith and RJ who
he said goodbye to at the end of The
Walking Dead there's Connie and Ezekiel
and last but not least Carol we'll get
to her in a bit Isabelle awakens after
being drugged by Quinn to find herself
in an a opulent Mansion she learns that
luron has safely made it out of the city
and now that Quinn has made good on his
side of the bargain it's time for her to
make good on hers Quinn wants that old
Isabelle back and Isabelle she says is
locked away and Quinn is willing to wait
telling her multiple times throughout
the episode he is willing to put in the
work to regain her love heck even
brought her her favorite Monae from the
club to make her feel more at home
Laural watches Alan a devout Muslim pray
remember that the union of Hope isn't
entirely Christian but a union of
multiple faiths that have Allied
together around luron as this savior
likee figure I thought it was pretty
sweet that even though Daryl doesn't
believe in God he overhears lauron
praying for Daryl's friends aan tells
Daryl that the nest is led by a man
named loang a name that translates to
Diamond surely this person can help
Daryl with a boat to get back home darl
also mentions that it's a promise that
drives him to get back home I'm guessing
it's his promise made to Carol just
Gathering us some fuel I'll be there
about a week I promise Isabelle doesn't
have what it takes to kill Quinn almost
stabbing him with a Shard she ripped
from airor he says it's just him and her
now meaning Anna is out of the picture
something she isn't too happy
about on the radio Daryl manages to get
in contact with Carol he tells her he's
about a week away but the most
interesting piece of information here is
Carol telling Daryl that someone has
come back unfortunately the radio gives
out and we can't tell who this person is
but my money is on either Michonne or
Rick we know that they have their own
spin-off titled the ones who live coming
out sometime in 2024 back at Camp alen
has fallen to a group of zombies There's
this Smoky one over here who I'm
guessing is one of the Bron or flaming
kind asan gives Daryl his pocket watch
with the engraving of m Michelle and
tasks Daryl with getting the kid to the
nest after burying him the next day
Daryl is furious when he finds someone
has Cut the Rope to their boat and
that's someone is lauron he says some
pretty mean stuff here like calling him
a worthless and saying he should
have left him but it isn't until lauron
explains why he did this that Daryl has
a change of heart everyone in Laurel's
life has left him and when Daryl drops
him off at the nest he'll leave him too
he just doesn't want to be alone
speaking of someone who's alone Isabelle
contemplates suicide but notice how her
demeanor changes once she receives this
secret message Marie the servant
exclaims that it's from one of
Isabelle's friends we never find out
what's on this message but soon after
she reads it she tells Quinn she's
willing to try and make their
relationship work she goes from almost
suicide to accepting Quinn maybe this
message tells her that Quinn will be
arrested maybe it tells her that lural
and Daryl have been caught but who
exactly sent it it could be Anna but
she's not necessarily Isabelle's friend
it could be someone from The Nest it
could also be fuo Amil or Sylvie who
will see have come to attend Jana's show
this must also mean the servant Marie is
in on it for if there was anything
incriminating in this message and she
was on Quinn's side she surely would
have told her boss the r tells Daryl he
doesn't want to go to the nest rather to
go with him back to America the rals
never had a father figure except for
Father John back at the Abbey but their
conversation is cut short when a group
of Jana's men can be seen in the
distance Daryl tells Lon to follow the
river until he comes across MOS Michelle
he's going to take down these men all by
himself a task that sees him actually
getting caught and Daryl is pretty
freaking tough he's willing to lose his
eye rather than divulge the whereabouts
of the kid but theal doesn't listen to
Daryl and reveals himself saving Daryl's
eye in another flashback we see how
Daryl got on that tanker he got in an
altercation with a man named Juno who
purposely killed a kid named TJ in order
to get another cord of gas it seems his
fight with the man was enough to get him
imprisoned on the tanker Quinn presents
Isabelle with some gorgeous diamonds as
they make their way to J she has invited
people from all over France including
the union of Hope to witness a very
special event she's also called this
deal day no doubt a nod to Charles deal
the French President and leader of the
free French people during World War II
deal led the establishment of the fifth
Republic and here Jana says she's
bringing about the sixth we'll see faloo
Emil and Sylvie in line for the event
they don't look like prisoners rather
witnesses to what's about to transpire
Anna has turned on Quinn informing Jana
about his bribe to get Lon and Daryl out
of Paris this ends with Quinn imprisoned
alongside Daryl who says he's sorry for
getting caught Isabelle is reunited with
luron who has gotten some time to
familiarize himself with Jan it seems
Jan wants to use luron as a prop to
control the union of Hope wanting him to
make an appearance at her event to show
the people she's not their enemy one
line I found really interesting here was
lauron
saying it makes me think Jana lost a
child and this is what motivates her she
wants to protect people because she
wasn't able to protect her own child
after all she lives in a home literally
called mother's house and the way she
held that baby in episode 3 was really
creepy the tanker is filled with zombies
fresh for experimentation we'll see two
signs here one that says do not feed and
another that says feed so maybe there
are some experiments on how zombies
react based on how much they've had to
eat knowing he's just going to be used
as zombie feed Daryl fakes an illness
and uses the opportunity to kill his
captors freeing the zombies in the
process to make his Escape in the fry
the variant zombie who is chained up
escapes narrowly killing Daryl before he
drops a Lifeboat and is knocked out this
occurred somewhere on the Gulf of kadi
and he'll float for several days before
landing in the south of France Jan makes
an impassioned speech about ushering in
a New France one that offers a hope for
the future while crushing the enemies of
the past enemies she refers refers to as
being the ones who quote gave us this
disease but I'm not exactly sure what
she hopes to accomplish by creating
super zombies it seems just as bad as
creating the zombies themselves to her
the cure to the zombie curse must come
from the zombies themselves this is in
direct opposition to the belief of the
Union of Hope who believe the Cure is
lon now it looks like Daryl must fight
off one of these variant zombies whose
eyes turn jet black and veins pop after
being injected with an unknown substance
it's likely whatever the scientist was
testing on a few episodes ago however
that ended with the zombie self-
exploding in under 18 seconds will this
zombie meet the same fate or have the
scientists perfected their serum in
order for these superpowered zombies to
last longer well it seems Kad knows
what's going to happen as he tells Daryl
today is the day he dies remember K
thinks Daryl killed his brother but that
was actually marabel who we saw once in
episode one and never heard from again
so the question then becomes where do we
go from here there's only one more
episode left in this season and a whole
ton of questions yet to be answered so
now we head over to the trailer
sleuthing section to see what's in store
and there it is m Michelle the home of
the nest we'll see Daryl walking away
from it alone suggesting that he is
successful in getting lural there Daryl
at a cemetery with different faiths is
this a World War II grave site or
something the Union has put together
since they're all from different faiths
darl Isabelle Sylvie and Lon with a big
fire in the background it suggests they
all make it out alive from m
Daryl fights off some zombies on a
Hilltop and if you look closely you can
see what could be a German World War II
bunker I could be wrong but I found
these images of bunkers on the French
Coast surrounded by grass that looks a
lot like the ones in the trailer here's
K holding sylv and luron at gunpoint
maybe Sylvie tries to help luron Escape
in this underground tunnel Daryl stabs a
Jan Soldier zombie with an axe that
looks like it could be the same axe he
was given to defend himself against the
variant zombie so it looks like luron
and Daryl surviv but somehow get split
up Isabelle is separated from luron but
later in the trailer we'll see her fight
off what appears to be zombie Quinn Lon
here takes Daryl's Axe and kills his own
father that is if you believe it's
really his dad Emil helps Daryl get out
of some chains and here we see Daryl in
some Old Abbey I would not be surprised
if this is the nest perhaps he's
contemplating leaving Lon the way this
zombie just rips itself off of Daryl's
ax is pretty crazy Daryl's going to have
one hell of a fight but then there's
also Kon to contend with with this being
the season finale I would not be
surprised if he ends up dead but now I
turn it over to you what do you think
will happen in the final episode I want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below thanks for watching
please make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory YT
until next time remember Daddy loves you
very
much